have made it to our final cake of the
day
it's the sam's club cheesecake and
trivia the first cheesecake was made
in ancient greece way back in 776
bc which stands for before cheesecake
right
you should the athletes at the first
ever
olympics ate cheesecake for energy and
vigor
huh that's funny after i eat this i just
want to be like on the couch and passed
out
i know i haven't had the sam's club
before get ready to have your
doors blown off ross
she does not lie about cheesecake that
is so good speaking of
old classics that stand the test of time
chess
a game that's over 1 500 years old
is 2020's biggest hit because nbc news
reports that chessboards are selling out
everywhere
sales are up get this number 87
wow after the success of netflix's the
queen's gambit
and the fact that they have so many
people obviously
at home this is the perfect potent
cocktail yeah it's always been too
complicated for me i'm going to stick to
checkers
okay right that's i think checkers i'll
play checkers with you
done i can handle checkers chess not so
much all right
look what i got everyone it's my whistle
which means it's time for smart smart
espn reports the olympics just got a
brand new sport
and it's not what you think break
dancing is now an olympic sport
it'll premiere at the summer olympics in
paris i mean it still means i have no
shot at a gold medal ever unless they
you know put like steel magnolia quoting
[Laughter]
as a sport another dope thing what would
you
do ross if you found something
worth thousands of dollars in your brand
new home i'd do the right thing
[Laughter]
i'd like to think i would do the right
thing and call the previous owner and
say hey you left something behind
well that is exactly the decision that
our next guests made wow
james and clarissa munford good
morning.com reported that the couple
stumbled upon
25 thousand dollars
worth of coins hidden in their closet
well now i didn't know it was that much
drew
well let's ask james and clarissa why
they're such good people
james and clarissa
how do you know how to do the right
thing how do you do it teach us
all our faith in god
so in our parents and grandparents they
taught as well
were you tempted for one second to keep
it just one second james
i wasn't
clarissa theresa pleads the fifth on
this one would you like to address that
one second one second i think that's
fair
i think that's totally fair and then
when you told the previous owners like
oh we found 25 grand worth of stuff here
what did they say
he was very surprised he he forgot they
even left him down in the drawer where i
found him in
so he was just very gracious and very
happy that
you know we notified him other coins i
just figured it was a family heirloom
they need to be returned back to them
i mean you could have used the money i
heard you have repairs on your house
like what projects are you working on
right now mostly flooring
right now because the house had a lot of
carpet and
need some um dallas fans done and now
um they're gonna get started upstairs
gosh you guys are such good people
i feel like we all need to step up our
game
in honor of james and clarissa and i
just
i don't believe that good deeds go
unseen
and kindness is so contagious and so is
karma
yeah and 84 lumber is the nation's
largest privately held
building materials supplier owned by
maggie hardy
knox and when they heard about your
story and
wanted to honor you so they're gonna
give you 25
000.
oh my god
[Applause]
you know what that really is karma and
sometimes i don't feel like i see it
quick enough
and this is reaffirming
my you know hope and faith in life
that good things happen to good people
and
84 lumber has a passion for giving back
to
the communities it serves in 2020 alone
this company made over a million dollars
in charitable donations great
and thank you for being the example
of true integrity thank you thank you
for having me thank you for having me
[Music]
james and clarissa thanks for being you